[Music]  for over 200 million years these  creatures have roamed the earth but now  their future is uncertain  this is the american horseshoe crab  [Music]  found along the atlantic coastline of  north america the american horseshoe  crab spends the majority of its time in  shallow waters but comes to shore to  mate  the crab has ten eyes the two most  obvious ones are on the top of its shell  but the others are on the tail and near  the mouth  [Music]  horseshoe crabs are harvested for their  blood which has helped prevent illnesses  across the globe but with the  development of their natural habitat and  over harvesting this once abundant  animal has now seen such a rapid decline  in numbers that they are considered a  vulnerable species  this is the american horseshoe crab  [Music]  you